what does a monster look like to you
what figures slither and claw their way
into your nightmares chasing you down
endless halls and stalking you through
the dark until you wake up screaming
maybe you imagine something tall and
lean bony arms reaching for you from
atop impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial
killer in a hockey mask wielding a
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face
what's so scary about that a face can't
run after you can't grab you by the
ankles and pull you under the bed a face
can only
look it may be unsettling to behold it
might send a chill down your spine but
the worse it can do is make you a little
uncomfortable and if you can't stand it
any longer you could always just close
your eyes but walk away and be done with
it right if that's what you think if you
don't believe in monsters that can hurt
you without lifting a finger then you're
the type to fall victim to a very
special
very intelligent
mask in the hollowed halls of the scp
foundation there is a containment cell
outfitted with a hermetically sealed
glass case surrounded by steel iron and
lead there are guards posted outside
along with a trained psychologist if you
are ever brave and foolish enough to
enter that room you'll see a simple
white porcelain comedy mask with a
peculiar black substance leaking from
its eyes and mouth whatever this slime
touches surfaces begin to corrode to rot
away into puddles of black liquid you
might notice the same liquid trickling
slowly down the walls of the room
corrupting everything in its path as
unsettling of a sight as it is if you
approach the mask to take a closer look
you will find yourself overcome by an
intense nearly irresistible urge to pick
it up and put it on to wear it to let it
consume you from the inside out and
puppet your body while your brain simply
turns off
like an extinguished flame you'll simply
be gone
then who knows what the mask will do
it won't be your concern anymore that's
for sure but thankfully you haven't gone
into the room with the porcelain mask
you haven't let it cast its spell on you
not yet at least it's waiting for you
there in the room with black slime
oozing down its walls and it will wait
patiently for as long as it needs to
after all what's a mask without a face
to wear it
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask sat in its containment cell
immobile as always it didn't really have
much of a choice in the matter the
foundation had chosen selfishly to
revoke its host privileges once upon a
time they offered it bodies to choose
from mannequins dummies and wooden dolls
it could adorn and pilot they didn't
last as long as an organic living host
of course but it was something it was a
taste of freedom this dreadful news
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its surroundings
this dreadful new situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its expression from comedy to tragedy
but it was determined to still find
something to laugh about even without a
body trapped in this infernal box there
had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment human minds were
fragile things the mask had learned this
over the infinite years of its life if
one could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would buckle completely in almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend a confidant
once suitable trust had been built up
the mask could persuade the person to
bring it a host or perhaps even offer up
themselves in sacrifice if flattery
didn't work there were other potent
approaches to take for a being without
ears the mask was a good listener it
picked up on things that no human ever
could the darkest secrets buried in a
person's mind if it caught wind of
something especially juicy and ruinous
it could leverage that threaten to
expose an affair a crime or perhaps
something even worse
something
unspeakable
if praise failed and so did blackmail
there was always good old supernatural
intimidation all the mask needed was for
someone to be left alone with it for a
long enough period of time
then its invisible tendrils could snake
out into their defenseless mind weaving
and poking around leaving a lingering
sense of cold dread of incomprehensible
whispers in long dead tongues
what a delight containment had been in
the early days when the foundation had
not yet figured out the mask's true
capabilities when they would leave
security personnel with weak wills and
minimal training standing guard in the
mask's field of influence for hours at a
time as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free
will
thanks to the helpers it had been able
to mold out of those hapless victims
they had been there to break open its
case and carry it to freedom but every
time the other guards thwarted the
attempts shooting its helpers and
rendering them utterly useless then the
foundation increased its security
something about the unacceptably high
homicide rates among staff assigned to
scp-035
how utterly boring how truly
pathetic
still the mask had found ways to occupy
itself even without any more playthings
it had grown stronger with its boredom
stretching its influence beyond organic
beings and into the very room itself its
evil enriching and deepening like a fine
wine in the depths of a cold cellar over
the months the walls of
scp-035's containment cell had begun to
secrete the same black slimy substance
that would pour from the mask's eyes and
mouth the liquid dripped down the walls
in deliberate formations patterns that
became increasingly easy to recognize
phrases in italian latin ancient greek
all detailing ritual sacrifices and
mutilations the mask took time to
describe the sacrificial victims in
great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that
it knew would read the translations the
walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more fragile by the day
anyone within 10 meters of the mask
could feel this strength too they would
leave the area complaining of
unintelligible whispers of loud cruel
laughter and a lingering sense of nearly
insurmountable despair it was as if they
knew on some level that no one was truly
safe eventually the mask would find a
way to come for them all the glass was
weakening and soon the mere thought of
escape would make it shatter into pieces
then perhaps the mask could finally get
its deepest desire
revenge
it wanted nothing more than to try to
make the foundation pay for imprisoning
it for taking away its host privileges
for trying harder and harder to contain
the kind of power that should have had
them falling to their knees in worship
the mask seethed with hatred day in and
day out it had seen the crumbling of the
roman empire the beheading of kings the
decimation of armies it was not going to
be captured by a bunch of rats in lab
coats without dire consequences
befalling them
maybe it couldn't move from its prison
cell at the moment but it also knew that
it was surrounded on all sides by
dangerous beasts capable of reducing the
sight and all who had dared to oppose
the mask to a pile of smoldering rubble
if it could only find its way onto one
of their faces it would show them all
just what it was capable of as the
piercing sound of an alarm echoed down
the hall the sound of screams and chaos
following shortly after the mask's
frowning face curved into a broad
menacing
smile
what was it that had escaped the lizard
perhaps the giant grinning man whatever
it was it seemed that the action was
heading right toward 035's containment
cell perhaps today was the day
finally
the scp foundation
would fall outside the masked cell
security officer harper was running for
dear life though his more rational mind
knew he was living on seconds not even
minutes of borrowed time his animal
brain kept his legs pumping desperately
trying to avoid the screaming howling
predator hot on his heels harper looked
over his shoulder and screamed as a long
white arm reached for him
scp-096 the shy guy its toothline jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle
that face that terrible terrible face an
absolute death sentence to all who saw
it he'd seen what he thought was a crack
in the otherwise perfect seal of 096's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplaced
ray of light and he made out the vague
shape of a face in the darkness that's
when the weeping started harper knew in
that moment his life was over the
correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close
their eyes while he stood there and
accepted his fate minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further but humans
rarely have perfect reasoning even less
so when facing mortality back in the
present the shy guy made a perfect lunge
grabbing harper in its iron clutches and
barreling through the adjoining wall the
nearby guards scattered terrified
keeping their eyes on the floor they
might get a slap on the wrist for
temporarily abandoning their posts but
they weren't going to die guarding some
stupid evil mask speaking of the
possessive mask was surprised to feel
two new presences enter its chamber
through the now destroyed wall these two
presences soon became just one as
scp-096
quickly and totally annihilated security
officer harper leaving nothing left the
mask couldn't see per se seeing as it
had no actual sensory organs but it felt
around this new guest with its many
psychic tendrils taking in this strange
totality the creature was powerful no
doubt about that and it elicited fear
from those fools at the scp foundation
but the mask noticed its brain waves
were extraordinarily
muted humans to the mask's vest and
malicious consciousness weren't the
sharpest knives in the drawer but
compared to this thing's mind they were
a pile of tempered katanas it barely
thought at all the mask would have to
dig deeper to find anything it could use
meanwhile
scp-096 finally began to calm down the
one who had seen it had been annihilated
bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out
and replaced by the standard low but
constant hum of anxiety and despair it
would wait until its head was bagged and
it was dragged back to the dark same old
same old all the way to the end of time
that's when it felt something else it
started as a faint buzz an
unintelligible whisper and it was almost
like a door opened in the back of its
head something stepped in and took a
seat
something about the voice frightened and
comforted as cp096 at the same time it
spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
than the creature had heard in a long
time and yet something about the way it
spoke implied evil in its intent
i know what you want
i know what you fear
wouldn't it be nice
if they could never look at you again
all you need to do
little by little 096 felt more of these
strange thoughts filling up the
emptiness in its head replacing the few
little thoughts the creature itself had
it felt itself lifting its hands from
the ground lifting them and reaching
towards
something a glass box the glass
shattered and those long white fingers
reached for something within a mask just
like the voice had said a mask to stop
people from looking
at its face
yes
yes
[Music]
scp-096 lifted the mask to its face
feeling black liquid that burned its
skin dripping from the porcelain and put
it on and in that moment everything
changed the shy guy's body began to
seize up rattling as the mask unleashed
a web of psychic tendrils through its
body mapping out across every inch like
a new nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to sublimate
oh this
was going to be fun
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its hind legs
its spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance the mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin
burning and fizzling with the gooey
black secretions but growing back just
as quickly the foundation had every
reason to fear it now
a group of security personnel had
gathered in the ragged hole where the
chamber's north wall used to be some
were wielding white firearms the guard
at the front was carrying an opaque
black bag the mask laughed with its new
body and turned to the crowd the second
they saw it on 096's body their faces
fell for a moment their bodies went
slack with terror this situation was
unprecedented what course of action
could they possibly take at a time like
this it looked at the bag held by the
leader of the security force and
projected a single thought into his mind
before any of the guards even had a
chance to open fire the mask lunged
forwards using the long terrible arms of
the shy guy to tear through the guards
they were dead in seconds their bodies
strewn about the hallway the mask's
porcelain was twisted into a wide
sadistic grin it could tell that it was
about to have some real fun around here
and once it slaughtered everyone here it
could finally stretch its legs out in
the open again true freedom to spread
misery fear and pain everywhere it went
there were just a few hundred members of
foundation personnel that needed to turn
into corpses first more containment
breach alarms sounded around the site as
the mask began its rampage running
through the hallways and tearing apart
any unfortunate foundation personnel it
could get 096's hands on
guards researchers administrative staff
and even one extremely unlucky janitor
in hallway c6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and you're home free this new
composite creature was a different story
it could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building in teams
heavily armed with anti-mimetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
over calms that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a detachment of mtf eta 10
also known as see no evil was operating
on a case in close proximity given their
specialization in anomalies with a
memetic visual property many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before that
at least gave them experience in half
this situation and one operative among
them sergeant henrique ramirez would be
the one to bring this nightmare to an
end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreak havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingents of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the halls making
sure to induce maximum terror before
finally striking the killing blow every
single one of them died with a head full
of demonic whispers it told them of the
mask's eternal dominion now it had found
the perfect host nothing on earth would
stop it humans would be mere ants under
its feet eta 10 touched down and entered
the building ramirez was point man
leading the others into the bowels of
the blood-drenched containment site
they'd been briefed on what they were
heading in for 096 and 035 had reached
symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with extreme caution they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
they finally encountered the monster
that they realized just how outmatched
they were despite their best efforts the
combined speed intelligence and ferocity
of the mask's new form allowed it to
make short work of 8-10 only ramirez was
left heavily injured even if a miracle
happened he knew he wasn't getting out
of here alive the mask grabbed him with
one of 096's claws and lifted him up it
would take its time with this one make
him suffer watch him squirm destroy his
mind ramirez felt the mask's psychic
tendrils penetrate the membrane of his
mind those whispers those terrible
whispers reciting all his worst fears
with terrible glee his gun was out of
ammo his knife was broken all he had
left on him was a pocket mirror and that
was his eureka moment it was a long shot
but it was also his only shot he reached
out and grabbed the bottom of the mask
pulling for dear life his other hand
shot into his pocket and grabbed the
mirror opening its lid with a deft flick
of his thumb it was too fast for the
mask to even register what was going on
ramirez forced his eyes shut and lifted
up the mirror the mask saw its own
reflection in the glass as the bottom of
its face came loose revealing the
reflection of the face underneath the
mask squeezed killing ramirez but it was
already too late it had finally seen the
face of its host and that would cost it
dearly the mask felt a sudden and
tremendous pushback to its psychic
forces a blind despair and then rage
that choked out everything
scp-096 began to sob and howl somehow
the mask was no longer in control
despite its psychic protests the 096
reached up and tore the terrible mask
from its face tossing it against the
wall with such force that it was
embedded in the brickwork its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were
what the hell just happened and the next
thought that crossed the mind of the
site director was request site transfer
for zero three five as soon as possible
don't want a repeat of this incident
anytime soon now go check out scp-035
the possessive mask and
scp-096 shy guy escape incident
096-1-8 containment breach for more
videos on today's terrifying combatants